[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره اعلن الرئيس الروسي
تعليق بلاده ابتداء من امس العمل بمعاهده
للحد من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه تصريح بوتين
جاء قبل يومين من دخول حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا عامها الثاني وفي خطابه السنوي
امام الجمعيه البرلمانيه الروسيه طلب
بوتين من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الاستعداد
لاختبار الاسلحه النوويه اذا بدات
الولايات المتحده بذلك
وفي اول رد فعل امريكيين وصف وزير
الخارجيه القرار بالمؤسف للغايه وغير
المسؤول وعبر بلنكر عن استعداد بلاده
للحديث مع روسيا بشان الحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه في اي وقت
ومن بولندا اعرب رئيس الامريكيه عما سماه
التزام بلاده الثابته تجاه اوكرانيا
وسيادتها وقال اننيتو بات اقوى من اي وقت
مضى وان الديمقراطيه ستنتصر حتما حسب
تعبيره
ميدانيا تحتدم المعارك في شرق اوكرانيا
فقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع في جراث
عنيفه في انحاء متفرقه من مدينه دنيتك
باقليم دومباس فقال موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسي ان ميليشيات اقتحمت دفاعات الجيش
الاوكراني الشماليه مدينه بخموت وانها
تتقدم بشكل متزامن من المحور الجنوبي
للمدينه
واعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه انها
تتصدى لمحاولات التقدم الروسيه في محيط
بخموت وفي سبعه محاور قتال اخرى في دمباس
شركه كلا من وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
الروسيين بحرمان مقاتليهم من الذخيره
ومحاوله تدمير فاغنر معتبرا ان تلك
الافعال تعادل الخيانه وقال ان ذلك تسبب
في خسائر متزايده في الصفوف قوات فاغنار
في المعارك حول بخموت وفي تزيين اشتكى من
ان المسؤولين يحرمون مقاتلين فاغنر من
امداداتهم بسبب العداء الشخصيه له
يصدر رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه فاليري
غراسي موف ووزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو امرا
بعد اخر بمنع تقديم الذخيره لشركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه
ومساعدتها في النقل الجوي وصلتني معلومات
للتو تفيد بانهم رفضوا طلبا لنا للحصول
على الات للحفر
وقد نفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه المعلومات
التي تفيد بوجود نقصا في الذخيره لدى
القوات الروسيه ونقلت رويترز عن الوزاره
قولها ان جميع التصريحات بشانه نقص
الذخيره غير صحيحه على الاطلاق
قدرت اللجنه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لغربي
اسيا الاسكو التابعه للامم المتحده عدد
المعتمدين على الدعم الانساني بشمال سوريا
باكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص وقالت الاسكوا
في تقرير جديد لها ان تسعه ملايين شخص
تضرروا في سوريا نتيجه الزلزال
اكدت نقابه الصحفيين التونسيين امير محمد
احاله
النشطاء نشطاء من المجتمع المدني على
التحقيق في تهم تتعلق بالتحريض على
العصيان والاعتداء على موظف اثناء اداء
مهامه وذلك على خلفيه تحرك احتجاجي مناهض
للاستفتاء على الدستور في يوليو الماضي من
بين الذين تم استدعائهم للتحقيق نقيب
الصحفيين التونسيين بعد الاجلاصي
وقال الرئيس سعيد الى تونس لن تقبل موصفه
بالتدخل الخارجي من جهه يقال رئيسه وحركه
النهضه راشد الغنوشي ان مثوله امام قاضي
التحقيق هو ثمره جديده من ثمرات ما وصفه
بالانقلاب اضاف الغنوشي انقلاب يستهدف كل
الكيانات الوطنيه وقد تم الابقاء على
الغنوشي في حاله السراح بعد التحقيق معه
فيما يعرف بقضيه تكثير الامنيين
انتهى الموجز في
[موسيقى]